hey what's up YouTube my name is Jake
Rieger and this is exactly what you
think it is it's an introduction to
flask for Python so this is what we're
gonna be doing here I'm pretty much
gonna start from the ground up and we're
going to go through each building block
of flasks until we have created a basic
crud application it's not going to be
anything too special don't get don't get
excited it's just going to be a little
like to do task master app and then
finally we'll top it off by deploying to
Heroku I feel like I should mention now
before we continue on here that this
tutorial does assume some prior
knowledge of Python how Python code is
written it also assumes you know HTML
CSS you don't have to know it too well
for this tutorial we don't write a whole
lot but knowing how to write a basic
HTML page would certainly be helpful
otherwise it's pretty bare-bones you
should be able to follow along pretty
easily if you know how to write code in
general alright so this is what we're
actually gonna be making here a little
application called taskmaster it's
basically just a to-do list all right as
you can see it says you have no new
tasks create one below so let's do that
do the dishes so as you could see it
pops up in a little table here we've got
our tasks the date it was added and some
actions so we've got a delete action and
an update action let's go ahead and
check out the update action here brings
us to a new page where we can do exactly
what you would think update the tasks so
I'm just gonna go ahead and change this
to do the dishes and the laundry click
update and there you go it's updated in
the table do the dishes and the laundry
and then if we had completed it and we
don't want it on our list anymore we can
just click delete there it goes
alright so that's what we're gonna be
creating alright so let's start out with
setting up our environment so we need to
install Python obviously 3.6 or newer I
believe the current version is three
point seven point something and pip then
we're going to install the virtual and
virtual environment package from pip
we're going to create our project
directory set up folders all of that
create a virtual environment and then
we're going to install the required
packages and that should be enough to
get us going so let's do that so we'll
start by just typing in python into
google here and over to python.org go to
download and just click the link if
you're on Mac or Linux you have Python
installed already it should be Python
2.7 I don't remember if python 3 comes
installed already but as you could see I
have Python 2.7 installed and I also
have Python 3 point 6 point 1 so I'm
good and this is how you check your
current version here if you're on Mac or
Linux the command corresponds to the
version so you use Python if you want to
use Python 2.7 and use the Python 3
command if you want to use Python 3 if
you have it installed and this is the
same for pip you use pip if you're
installing packages for python 2 and you
use pip 3 if you're installing packages
for python 3 alright so I already have
Python installed so I don't have to
click download the next thing we need to
do is actually set up our work
environment so I'm in Visual Studio code
here use whatever text editor IDE you
like I would strongly recommend Visual
Studio code though I think it's by far
the most powerful the easiest to use
quickest workflow anyways I'm gonna go
ahead and click open folder here and I'm
just gonna go ahead and actually I'm
already in my projects folder so this is
fine put this wherever you'd like
I'm gonna go ahead and call this flask
introduction and then just click open
and then I can close that and then hit
control tilde to open up a terminal here
in our current folder and I'm gonna go
ahead and type pip 3 install oops
Virtual env virtual end and I already
have this installed so this is going to
go really quick you most likely won't
and this is going to be what allows us
to create our virtual environment here
and if you're wondering why we do that
and don't just install the packages
globally it's so that if we wanted to
work with other people if we wanted to
you know work on a project collaborate
it makes it so that all of the
requirements all the packages that are
needed are contained within the project
itself and not on your system in other
directories so you can transfer the
project around and everyone can just
install the requirements into the
working directory and have the exact
setup that you had so it makes it easier
to work with other people and that's
that's pretty much the gist of it so
that's what we're gonna do so now that
we have virtual and installed we're
gonna go ahead and type virtual whoops
virtual and env and env is the name as
you can see just popped up here that
could really be any name you want you in
V's the convention it's short you'll
have to type it so alright next up we
need to activate the environment so
we're gonna go ahead and type source env
bin and activate and hit enter and as
you can see this little env and
parenthesis appeared that's how we know
we are now inside of our virtual
environment so anything we do or install
for Python will be contained inside of
this environment and it won't install
anywhere globally on our system so let's
go ahead and install the requirements so
just go ahead and type it 3 install and
we need flask and we need flask whoops
flask SQL alchemy like that I'm gonna go
ahead and hit enter and that's going to
install everything we need alright now
that that's installed I'm going to go
ahead and create a new file here I'm
gonna call it app hi I'm gonna hit enter
and I'm going to go ahead and start
writing a very
very basic the most basic flask app you
can write but it's going to give us an
outline for the entire application so
before I do that just so you guys can
see I'm going to go ahead and up the
font size I think 18 should be pretty
big yeah that works okay so the first
thing we need to do is import flask so
we're going to type from flask import
flask with a capital F next we need to
set up our application so we're going to
go ahead and type AB equals flask and
then in here we're going to put
underscore underscore name underscore
underscore and that's just referencing
this file so next up we need to create a
index route so that when we browse to
the URL we don't immediately just 404
and in flask you set up routes with the
app of route decorator so at route and
then in here you're just going to pass
in the URL string of your route we're
gonna hit enter and then we're going to
define the function for that route so
we're just going to call this index and
for now we're just going to return a
string so do a hello world and then
finally we're going to type if
underscore underscore name whoops
equals equals underscore underscore main
underscore underscore app run and then
for now we're going to set debugging
equal to true so if we have any errors
they'll pop up on the web page and we
can see so that's pretty much it that is
a very basic flask application if we run
this it should work it should pull up a
page that says hello world so let's go
ahead and see if that is the case come
down to my terminal and I'm going to
execute this with Python 3 so I'm going
to type Python 3 app PI come on there we
go and it starts up a web server here so
it's just localhost and then the ports
5,000
and there you go
hello world so as you could tell it's
pretty boring so far so let's spice it
up let's let's talk about static content
we'll go over some templates we'll go
over how to use CSS and JavaScript so
let's create some new folder so we're
going to create two we're going to call
the first one static and then we're
going to make one more and we're going
to call this templates and we're going
to go up to here and our import and
we're going to also import render
underscore template so let's create a
new file in here we're gonna call it
index.html I'm gonna come over to here
we're gonna change this from return
string to return render template we're
gonna call that file index.html and you
don't have to specify the folder the
name is that name for a reason it knows
to look in that folder so it's just the
name of the file yeah just gonna create
some boilerplate tml here just type
hello world - so we know our template is
what we're seeing and not that string
anymore so as you could see down here
it's automatically updating so we should
be able to refresh and see that we are
now reading from our template hello
world - all right so let's talk about
template inheritance now if you don't
know what that is it's basically you
create one master HTML file that that
contains kind of the the skeleton of
what each page is going to look like and
then you just inherit that in each other
page and insert code where you need it
but it's it basically makes it so you
don't have to write this every single
time you only have to write like this
and this what's relevant so if that
didn't make sense go ahead and show you
how it's done call it base HTML alright
so this is going to be our skeleton so
let's create the boilerplate code here
and then I'm just going to get rid of
this title and I'm going to create a
block I'm going to call it head
and I'm going to whoops and the block
alright so what's this doing this is
Jinja to send text this is a the
template engine that flask uses so
basically what we're doing here is we're
creating a block and the template and
this block is where we're going to
insert our code on all the other pages
that inherit this template so this is
pretty much outlining where we're going
to insert our own code for each page so
I'm going to make one more and I'm going
to call this body and then I'm going to
come over to index here I'm gonna get
rid of all of this and I'm gonna come up
here whoops
and type extends and then in quotes I'm
gonna put the name of the base template
here then I'm going to copy these blocks
that enter enter there we go okay so now
I can put whatever I want here so let's
create a so let's create a h1 and we'll
just say template sure and now if I load
this up we should see template so that's
not all that special you probably
thinking that seems like a lot of work
just to get pretty much what we just had
but this is all you have to do for every
page for pretty much the rest of your
website as long as it follows this
format and that includes things like
linking style sheets and scripts that
can all be done over here so you only
ever have to do it once I just realized
I had yeah he had her in the head tag
here my bad should still work yep okay
all right so now that we got templates
working here let's go ahead and talk
about static content so I'm gonna go
over to our static folder going to make
a new folder in here we call it CSS I'm
going to make a new file call it main
dot CSS
I'm just gonna put some basic rule sets
in here so body alright there we go so
just getting rid of the margin setting
the font family to sans-serif let's go
ahead and I'll link this in our base
HTML so we're gonna do link rel alright
and then in the URL here we can't just
type something like what would static
CSS main dot CSS this won't work so what
do we have to do we have to use some
more Jinja - syntax here if you remember
before well actually it's in this page
we were using the bracket percent this
is for stuff like if-else statements for
loops and these are for things you want
to be printed in I guess strings so this
is basically going to take the code you
write in here and it's going to give you
the the result of that as a string so we
need to use a function from flask called
URL 4 and I don't know if we have to do
this but I'm gonna go ahead and do it
anyways just import URL 4 and then I'm
going to put parentheses here and then
I'm going to put in quotes here single
quotes because this is a double quote
I'm going to put the name of the static
folder static I'm going to type file
name equals and then more single quotes
and then I'm going to type the name of
the file and you have to include any
subdirectories in this so since it's
static CSS main dot CSS we have to put
that in the file name so CSS slash the
main CSS and that should be enough to
link that's stylesheet so let's go ahead
and see and there you go
sans-serif no margin it's right up
against the edge it is linking our
stylesheet and this is the exact same
thing for JavaScript it would just be
file name equals Jess
AAS if that was the name of your
JavaScript that you were trying to link
alright so that does it for the basic
flask application all right I think
we're ready to talk about databases now
so I'm gonna go ahead and import SQL
alchemy
so from flask underscore SQL alchemy
import SQL alchemy alright let's go
under our app here and we're going to
add a config and this is going to be SQL
alchemy database uri so this is telling
our app where our database is located
and we're just going to be using SQLite
there are lots of resources online for
showing you how to do this with my
sequel or Postgres or whatever you want
to use but just to keep things simple
we're just gonna use SQLite so we're
just going to go ahead and type SQLite
colon and then three forward slashes for
or forward slashes is an absolute path
three is a relative path and we want a
relative path here because I don't want
to have to specify an exact location
I just wanted to reside in the project
location so I'm just gonna go ahead and
call this test dot BB so that's what our
database is gonna be is everything's
going to be stored in this test dot DB
file and then finally we need to
initialize our database so we're just
gonna type SQL alchemy pass in our app
like that
so our database is being initialized
with the settings from our at all right
so that's initializing the database now
we need to create a model here so we're
going to make a class and I'm just gonna
call this to do and this is a DB dot
model like that I can give myself
another new line there alright now that
we've got our class let's set up some
columns so the first one we needs an ID
column this is just going to be an
integer that references the idea of each
entry so this is of type DB column and
then this is an integer and so this is
going to be our primary key so we're
gonna set primary
equalsto true and then we're going to
create a text column here called content
and this is just going to be what holds
each task so this will be B B string and
then I'll say 200 characters I think is
a good amount and then I'm going to set
nullable equal to false because we don't
want this to be left blank we don't want
the user to be able to create a new task
and then just leave the content of that
task empty so then finally we just need
one more called 8 created and this is
more for bookkeeping than anything it's
not something the user really needs
access to so this is going to be bb8
time like that with the capital T and
then we're going to set the default here
I've got to come up to the top real
quick and import date time so from date
time import date time and then we're
gonna set the default equal to date time
at UTC now okay all right so basically
any time a new to-do entry is created
the date created will just automatically
be set to the time that it was created
so this we don't ever have to set
manually it'll always just be set
automatically all right and then finally
we just need a function that's going to
return a string every time we create a
new element so we're gonna go ahead and
tell it what to return here and we want
it to return tasks and then we'll just
call self dot ID so every time we make a
new element it's just going to return
tasks and then the idea of that task
that's just been created and that does
it for our model here so let's go ahead
and set up the database now I'm gonna
head down to the terminal and I'm gonna
just type o actually first I have to
activate my environment so let's do that
we
then activate there we go okay so now
that our environment is activated we can
go ahead and just start a interactive
Python three shell so I'm going to type
from app and pour EB so this is going to
go ahead and import into our interactive
shell this DB object up here so that
we're just going to type DVD create
underscore all and that should create
our database and you could see it popped
up right over here so then we can exit
out of that and now we have our database
setup if you remember from earlier I
showed you that task master application
we're going to go ahead and create that
now alright so in our index dot HTML
file here let's go ahead and get rid of
this header and I'm going to go ahead
and set up a div here I'm just going to
call this content and then I'm gonna
make a header just call us or just have
this a task master
then I'm gonna come down here I'm gonna
make a table so let's create a table row
table header task and then added for the
date that it was created and then
actions oops okay so that's those are
the three columns we'll have and then
I'm just going to leave this empty for
now we'll come back to this actually you
know what now I'm going to do this I'm
going to create another row and then I'm
not going to put anything in here and
make another one and I'm gonna make one
more and then I'm going to add two links
here and I'm gonna leave these empty for
now just have this a delete
and break here and paste one more in and
this one will say update okay so let's
go ahead and run our server here and see
what we've got now okay so there we go
says task master we've got a table and
we've got some links here for the
actions delete and update all right so
let's head on over to app dot PI here
and we're going to come down to our
index and we need to change something we
need to come up into our decorator and
after the route we're going to add an
option called methods and then we're
gonna set this equal to a list here and
this is going to be post in quotes and
then get in quotes so this is adding two
methods that this route can accept now
instead of just get by default we can
now post to this route as well and send
data to our database which is exactly
what we want to do all right so let's
head over to our index file here and
then under table we're going to add a
form and we're just going to set the
action URL to our index and then method
equals whoops host all right and then
let's create two inputs we're gonna have
a text input and a submit input so text
the name equal to content and the ID is
also content and then input again type
is submit value add task alright so
those are our two inputs for our form
let's go ahead and look at this and it
updated but everything is now all messed
up that's okay we'll fix that later not
worried about it right now all the
matters is that and we've now got the
form that we need alright so let's go
over this one more time nothing in the
head tag for now we're gonna actually we
can add a title if you want I'll just
call this
taskmaster update this and yeah it says
taskmaster okay so that doesn't matter
you can put whatever you want there but
uh I've got a div here called content
header taskmaster you I could say
whatever you'd like and then we're just
creating a table so I'm going to
collapse this for now so we can get the
whole thing in there so these are our
headers tasks added in actions and then
we've got one more row and we've just
kind of written the skeleton for this
for now because this is going to be
where each new task is added so this is
going to be updated dynamically which we
haven't gotten to yet but we will in
just a moment
alright that's pretty much it for the
HTML for now so let's head back to our
App pie file and then we're gonna come
down to our index route here and we're
gonna we're gonna change this a little
bit so we're gonna start with an if
statement if request dot method equals
equals post so this is going to say if
the request that's sent to this route is
post new stuff there and then else do
more stuff so this is pretty much what
we're looking at if post this is how
we're going to grab the task and put it
in our database otherwise we're just
pretty much looking at the the page so
under else here we can actually just put
render template and just have it show us
our page so this should work well it
won't because we're not running it so
let's do that first
alright name error requests is not
defined come up to our import here and
we just need to import that and that
should fix that and there we go
so it's still just showing us our page
and then if we were to submit that form
type error the view function did not
return a valid response because we're
not actually returning anything if I set
this to return hello
that should do exactly what it says
it'll return hello if we submit our
forum otherwise it's just going to show
us our page so we've set that up so
let's go ahead and actually put our
logic for adding a task in here
it's create a variable I'm gonna call
this task content and then that request
object again form for that forum we
created and then we're just going to
pass in the ID of the input that we want
to get the contents of which was content
so task content is equal to the contents
of this input right here so then I'm
just going to go ahead and create a
model for this as you can see our we
have our to-do model so let's create a
to-do object that's going to have its
contents equal to the content of that
input so now we've got our to-do model
all that's left to do is push it to our
database so we're going to try DB dot
session ad so we're adding this to our
database session this new task then we
want to commit so DB dot session commit
commit that to our database and then
finally we just need to return and we're
gonna return a redirect back to our
index which we have to come back up to
our import again and now we're going to
import redirect so it's going to create
a new task from that input it's going to
try to commit it to our database and
that's going to redirect us back to our
index page if that does happen to fail
just create an accept here and we're
just gonna return there was an issue
adding your test so just a plain string
with error message here is all we really
need this should generally speaking
never fail but just in case it does and
then we're going to come down to else
here and we're going to create a
variable called tasks
set this to a to do query order
underscore by to do date created not all
so what is this this is going to look at
all of the database contents in the
order they were created and it's just
going to return all of them so we're
just query in our database ordering them
by the day created so newest to oldest
and then we're just grabbing all of them
you could also do first to grab the
first which would be the most recent if
we're sorting by date we're just going
to grab them all and this is how we're
going to display all the current tasks
in that table and then we need to pass
this to our template and we're just
going to set tasks equal to tasks that
variable we just created and that does
it for our index form so let's head on
over to the index dot HTML and we just
need to add some quick code here we're
going to come down to this row I'm going
to indent this and then we're going to
do some Jinja to syntax here and then
we're just going to type for tasks in
tasks and this is going to grab all the
tasks in that task variable will be
passed to this template and then we just
need to end the for all right so then
we're just going to come up to our first
TD tag here and we're going to do double
curly braces and we're just going to
type task contents so this is going to
return the content of each task and then
we're going to do one more for the date
created and then we're just going to do
dot date so it doesn't return the time
as well because if you remember it's a a
time object right here day time we just
need the date so it created dot eight
and then over here we actually haven't
set up our delete route yet so I'm going
to leave that alone
but I go ahead and start up our app here
you could see our table disappears so
let's go ahead and add a task and as you
can see it pops up in our table so the
delete and update don't do anything yet
but as you can see pushing to our
database
working so we've got the create part of
our crud app done so I'm just real quick
I'm gonna copy over some CSS to clean up
this page a little bit as it's kind of
uh just kind of not very attractive
sitting there all the way in the corner
like that alright so let me refresh here
and there we go
so that's kind of what we were looking
at originally I'm actually gonna go
ahead and just do this real quick go
ahead and center align that text so
there we go okay so that's that's what
we had earlier all right so now that
we've got the create part done let's go
ahead and do the delete part because
that's the next easiest so let's head
over to our app top pie and we need to
set up a new route for this so I'm just
going to come under our index one here
at that route and then it's going to be
slash delete and then we need to get the
ID this number right here is going to be
the easiest way of identifying a unique
task because if we go by content or
anything like that this content could be
the same for multiple tasks so we need a
unique identifier which is what this
primary key is here for this will always
be unique you can never have a duplicate
so come over to here / delete slash and
then we're gonna put in a bracket here
int for integer colon and then the name
of the variable so we're just gonna call
this ID and and that's it for that
alright so then let's just find our
function here we'll call it delete pass
an ID as the variable that we need and
then we're ready to go so let's go ahead
and create a variable for the task that
we want to delete so task to delete and
then we're gonna query our database here
and we're going to do get so dot query
get underscore or underscore 404 ID so
this is going to attempt to get that
task by the ID and if it doesn't exist
it's just going to 404 so then let's do
a try then we're gonna do DB dot session
dot delete
and then we're gonna pass getting tasks
to delete whoops didn't mean to do that
then we're gonna come under there and we
need to commit this again commit and
then we're going to return a redirect
back to our home page and then if this
doesn't work we'll just print another
string with our error message so there
was a problem
deleting that task alright so that is
our delete route and this should
actually work I think we're good here
let's go ahead and run our app again and
we've got this task in here actually no
real quick we do have to come over to
our delete so let's do slash delete and
then double brackets here because we
want to get the idea of that current
task so task dot ID and that should if
we hover over this you could see down at
the bottom left there in the browser so
/ delete slash one so it's getting the
ID of this task so for cook delete
disappeared there we go so that's the
delete all right on to updating so let's
make one more route here I'm gonna call
it app that route slash update slash and
we're gonna do the same thing in tidy so
we're gonna grab the ID of the task we
want to update and then methods and we
need to do the same thing as earlier
with our index Raptors we're gonna be
posting so let's go ahead and do that
and then let's go ahead and create the
function so update ID and then return
for now just return nothing let's come
over to our index here and we're gonna
copy this paste it down here and instead
of slash delete will change this to
slash update and then we're going to
make one more template here and we're
going to call this update HTML and we're
gonna just copy our index.html here
we're going to get rid of this table
because we don't need to show all of our
tasks we just want to show the one that
we're updating changed this to update
tasks so then the action will be slash
update slash and then we'll grab that
whoops
task ID like that okay so this should be
our update page I'm going to go over to
our update route I'm gonna do if request
dot method equals post pass because
we'll add our code a minute here else
return render template update HTML okay
so there we go I'm just gonna go ahead
and run this real quick and make sure
that if we go to we need to make a new
test task here the update page okay so
it did work it's returning an error task
is undefined because I've called task ID
but if you notice in our function here
I'm not actually sending a variable
called task so let's come down actually
we'll do it up here we'll create a
variable called task equals to do that
query I think I typed that right yep dot
actually we could just copy this whole
thing okay there we go so same thing as
the delete we're grabbing the task we're
just getting the task from the ID here
because we're passing that into the URL
then we'll come down to here and we'll
pass that into our render template
function here and now this should work
there we go so it's not grabbing the
text from our task as you can see it
says do the dishes in the laundry when
we click update that's not in here so
let's auto populate that come over to
update and then we'll set the value of
this input this text input to grab this
instead of tasks that ite or ID task
contents so now that should
there we go show the text of the task so
then we want when we click update or
well it doesn't say update because we we
have to change that here forgot about
that
so there we go now if we click update
it's not doing anything the View
function did not return a valid response
because if you remember we're just doing
a pass here so let's go ahead and add
our update logic this is actually pretty
easy task content equals request form
content actually got this wrong task dot
content not task underscore content
equals request that form so we're just
setting this current tasks content to be
content in this forums input box and
then we just need to try DB dot session
commit and we don't have to add or
delete or anything we just have to
commit because we set the content right
here so we're not adding a new one we're
just updating and then we need to do a
return redirect back to our home page
and that's it for that so unexpected
indent Oh yep forgot our exception here
return there was an issue updating your
tasks all right should be good now yep
that mean to open Chrome let's go ahead
and update this task so let's just
change do the dishes and the laundry and
brush your teeth then click update and
there you go so we are now updating our
tasks let's go ahead and make another
task here so we can see that there are
multiple entries popping up in this box
here do the dishes and eat some broccoli
definitely didn't spell that right rock
Oly we're going with we're done with two
L's add tasks so there we go and then we
can update all of these individually
let's change that to banana
eat some banana
doesn't make sense but it doesn't need
to because we can just delete it I'm
gonna delete that and I'm gonna delete
that and now we have nothing so I'm
gonna add one more thing to our index
page I'm gonna add an if statement and
change it to syntax alright and this is
going to say if tasks and then we're
gonna do a filter here this is a Jinja
to filter it's called length this is
going to get us the length of that list
and if it's less than one so if there
are no entries in it we will go ahead
and create one more here and it's just
gonna say else so if there are entries
we want to show this table but if there
aren't any entries we want to just show
a header here that says there are no
tasks create one below and then close
off that and then we'll just copy this
Center style here for that as well so
now I think this is still updating
encountered unknown tag and to block
because we didn't end our if so let's
grab this end for here come under table
and then change this from end for to end
if and now we should be good there are
no tasks create one below it looks like
there's some formatting issues for ah
not totally sure how I managed to do
that but should be good enough okay
there we go and then if we make a new
task do the dishes add tasks that goes
away now we see her table so I believe
that's everything we've got everything
working so that is a basic crud app all
right so finally let's talk about
pushing to Heroku if you don't know what
Heroku is I'll go ahead and show you go
to Heroku comm it's pretty much a
service that lets you host any number of
different web apps whether it's no js'
Ruby on Rails PHP Python that could be
Django flash
what have you and they'll host your app
for you and pretty much run it off their
own servers and not your own so you can
also create databases through them and
it pretty much makes it really easy to
manage and run a web app without having
to set up your own web server so I
already have an account if you don't
just go ahead and click sign up and sign
up for free they have a free tier you
will have to use your credit card if you
want to add any of their database
functionality but since we were just
using SQLite we don't have to worry
about that so free tier is fine
so yeah just go ahead and sign up and
then once you've signed up go ahead and
look up Heroku CLI we need the
command-line interface here and it's
that first link just go ahead and click
that come down to download and install
here and you can see there are
installers for whatever system you're on
so just go ahead and install that and
then once that's installed let's head
down to our terminal here and type in
Heroku login and that's going to pull
this up I've already logged in before so
it knows my email if you probably
haven't before so just go and type your
sin hit enter type your password hit
enter and it should log you in just like
that alright now that that's done let's
go ahead and create an empty git
repository I feel like I should mention
that you do need it if you don't have
git installed just go ahead and go to
get - SCM comm and install it off of
there and then once that's installed
you'll be able to use the git command
line as well actually before we do that
we need to freeze our requirements and
actually before we do that we need to
install a dependency so let's go ahead
and make sure you're in your virtual
environment here we're gonna type pip 3
install and it's called unicorn GU and I
corn hit enter and go ahead and let that
install should go pretty quick and then
you can go ahead and freeze your
requirement so pip 3 freeze requirements
dot text and that's going to spit out
all our requirements in a text file here
and now that we're done with that we can
go ahead and initialize an empty it
repository so get in it so initialize
empty git repository git add and then
period just to add everything in the
directory and then that's done so then
we need to commit
I'll just say an app for the comment
here and then that's going to commit
everything to the repository so now we
can finally create our Heroku app so
Heroku create and then your application
name this can only be lowercase letters
you can only have dashes and numbers so
we're just going to create one called
flask crud app tutorial and I'm gonna
hit enter that's going to go ahead and
create our app so then we can type git
remote dash V and we could see where
we're pushing to so get Heroku calm and
then we're pushing that application we
just created so let's type git push
Heroku master hit enter and finally this
is going to push everything to Heroku
and I actually just realized we're
missing a crucial file here so I'm going
to let this finish up and it's not gonna
work and I will show you why in just a
second alright so it finished but it's
not gonna work I'm gonna go ahead and
open it up anyways I'm just gonna copy
that head to a browser type that in and
hit enter and we get an application
error why do we get an application error
well we're missing a file that tells
Heroku what to do with all these files
I've pretty much just pushed a directory
of files and Heroku is just kind of
sitting there twiddling its thumbs not
knowing what to do with them so we got
to tell it what to do with them so we
need to create a file called a proc file
so I'm just gonna go ahead and type
touch proc file with the capital P
there's no extension it's just proc file
and then we need one line it's really
short web : unicorn so we're gonna call
that library we installed well it's not
really a library it's so it creates a
web server and then we need to tell it
what file to create a web server for so
our app file app : app and that's it so
now if we get add everything git commit
dash M added proc file git push Roku
master hit enter and now it should work
so I'm gonna go ahead and let this do
its thing and then when I return
hopefully we'll have a working web app
on the Internet
all right so here we go let's go ahead
and check this out
and there you have it well I should
probably make sure it works first so I'm
gonna go ahead and add do the dishes
looks like it popped up there see if
update works do the dishes and eat some
broccoli looks like that's working let's
see if we can delete it and there we go
looks like everything's working in as
you can see this is running on HTTPS at
our application URL so this is running
on a live web server all right thanks
everyone for watching that does it
this git repository will be available
hopefully it'll be in the description I
hope you learn something I hope it was
helpful and I'll see you around